che cos'è il tempo
vedete quel ragazzo nella foto avrebbe
fatto un carrierone intellettuale
rettore teologo filosofo perfino vescovo
e santo ma quello che mi fa impazzire di
agostino si chiamava agostino in effetti
è che aveva inventato un sistema
bellissimo per non rispondere alle
domande quando gli si chiedeva una
domanda complicata agostino diceva se me
lo chiedete non lo so ma se non me lo
chiedete lo so che cosa è il tempo e il
tempo sembra che sia qualcosa che scorra
come il fiume che vedete in questa
fotografia e noi gli siamo sballottati
su questo fiume un po come delle barche
oppure al contrario noi siamo fermi nel
tempo come le rocce di questo torrente
ma davvero le cose stanno così
beh propriamente noi non vediamo
scorrere il tempo
noi vediamo delle cose che cambiano
delle cose che mutano
per esempio io sto guardando le lancette
di un orologio che si muovono ci sono
tanti eventi intorno a me ci sono degli
eventi lenti come la crescita dei figli
oppure la il fatto che i ghiacciai si
stanno sciogliendo oppure che qualcuno
perde i capelli questo evento è molto
veloce effettivamente quello che noi
vediamo il cambiamento delle cose non è
lo scorrere del tempo però sembra che
cambiamento delle cose score del tempo
siano insieme siano quasi due facce
della stessa medaglia
allora qualcuno ha provato a chiedersi
ma potrebbe darsi che il tempo scorra
anche se le cose effettivamente non
cambia non mutano
ecco questo è il tipico e generi domanda
incasinata la quale i filosofi adorano
cacciarsi e per provare a rispondere a
questa domanda così complicata
possiamo fare tutti insieme un
esperimento fatelo anche voi da casa
però non vi preoccupate non è un
esperimento
un esperimento frasi per finta è un
esperimento mentale
cosa sono gli esperimenti mentali
guardate sono quelle poche cose che ci
fanno non essere tanto odiati dai nostri
colleghi l'università perché gli
esperimenti mentali costano pochissimo
basta avere un po di immaginazione e un
po di rigore
quando abbiamo a che fare con questa
immaginazione
allora facciamolo insieme questo
esperimento mentale che cosa dovete fare
prima cosa
immaginatevi una situazione davvero
ferma ma ferma ferma l'avete in mente
fatto ecco probabilmente non è
sufficientemente ferma quello che dico
io che voi dovete immaginare una
situazione davvero immobili dove niente
accade una situazione in cui per assurdo
perfino gli elettroni che ruotano le
nubi elettroni intorno agli atomi beh si
fermano una sorta di gelata un po come
quel paesaggio che c'è nella fotografia
una gelata metafisica uno scenario alla
bella addormentata nel bosco
avete presente avete in mente questa
situazione molto strana ma almeno
concettualmente possibile bene se avete
in mente questa situazione abbiamo già
fatto un passettino avanti adesso
immaginate che ci siano al mondo tre
mondi 5 usato questi numerini bene
questi mondi sono particolari sono mondi
come il nostro le cose succedono si
giocano le parti di calcio la squadra
del cuore vince si tengano dei the dix
meravigliosi in questi mondi poi possono
comunicare una dall'altro per tempio si
telefonano mandano le mail fanno delle
conference
ma questi mondi hanno una caratteristica
ogni tanto cadono in letargo e ogni
tanto in questi mondi c'è una gelata
metafisica che dura esattamente un anno
il bello di questi mondi queste gelate e
metafisiche sempre il nostro esperimento
mentale cadono
una stratega d'enza regolare e lo
immaginate no in questo mondo accadono
ogni due anni
in questo ogni tre in questo ogni 5 bene
quando in un mondo in gelata metafisica
e gli altri non possono comunicare ma in
quel mondo anche se non succede niente
il tempo scorre perché perché negli
altri mondi succedono delle cose bene se
mi avete seguito fin qui siamo quasi
alla fine facciamo un ultimo passetto
che cosa succede una volta ogni 30 anni
una volta ogni 30 anni tutti e tre i
mondi caldo nella gelata in tutti e tre
mondi c'è lo scenario bella addormentata
del bosco e questo scenario dura un anno
e poi tutto si risveglia e tutto torna
alla vita
siete d'accordo ehi ma avete appena
ammesso che il tempo può scorrere anche
senza nessun cambiamento
bene se siete convinti di questo
abbiamo fatto un passetto in più per
capire che forse tempo e cambiamento
sono due aspetti la realtà che possono
essere almeno teoricamente sganciati
forse però quando parliamo di tempo
dell'anno chiedere gli scienziati per
gli scienziati il tempo è una cosa molto
particolare è un'altra dimensione dello
spazio tempo la quarta dimensione
in questa foto voi vedete tutta la
struttura dell'universo
la metafora che mi piace di più per
illustrare questa strana concezione del
tempo è quella di un film una pellicola
se ci pensate bene nella pellicola ci
sono tanti fotogrammi e in fondo la
nostra vita è fatta da tanti fotogrammi
uno di questi fotogrammi non si muove
nei cartoni animati non si muovono i
personaggi e la nostra illusione che
vede il movimento perché tutti in
qualche modo è statico beh tra il tempo
sapete c'è il futuro c'è il passato c'è
per esempio il mio preferito è sempre
stato il futuro se avesse avuto la
macchina del tempo sarei andato
sicuramente a vedere come stanno le cose
il futuro però come dice questa scritta
forse
il futuro non è più quello di una volta
di sicuro una cosa che ha attirato
l'attenzione di filosofi a capire come è
fatto il futuro per esempio il futuro è
lineare oppure a delle biforcazioni
ovvero la nostra storia il nostro
destino è univocamente determinata
oppure possiamo scegliere ea seconda di
come scegliamo le cose accadranno in
modo diverso lo ricordate il film
sliding doors in quel film c'era il
racconto che a un certo punto si biforca
va e sinistra se volete un riferimento
un po più dotto c'è un bellissimo
racconto di borges che parla esattamente
di questa cosa e che cosa ne è delle
possibilità non intraprese che cosa
succede
dal punto di vista metafisico ai nostri
rimpianti
le strade che non abbiamo preso bene
qualcuno potrebbe essere tentato per
andare a vedere come stanno le cose di
andarci nel tempo cioè di viaggiare
ecco questo è un altro fotogramma di un
altro famoso film interstellar in cui
degli astronauti si muovono molto
lontano nello spazio e quindi anche nel
tempo viaggiare il tempo è sempre stato
un sogno coccolato dalla c dalla
fantascienza e gli scienziati ci dicono
che forse non è fisicamente impossibile
certo che viaggiare nel tempo però
comporta cose strane
per esempio se noi tornassimo indietro
nel tempo potrebbe succedere che
potrebbe succedere che troviamo in noi
stessi il nostro doppio ma peggio ancora
noi potremmo tornare indietro nel tempo
e incontrare un bambino che è nostro
nonno e magari i colti da un raptus
omicida decidiamo di ammazzare questo
bambino che vado succederebbe
succederebbe qualcosa di veramente
strano e bizzarro in qualche modo nostro
nonno non avrebbe mai più incontrato la
nostra nonna non avrebbe mai più
generato nostro papa la nostra mamma è
nemmeno noi quindi potremmo essere al
mondo ma un momento la causa di questo
fatto è proprio il fatto che noi abbiamo
ucciso nostro nonno e allora allora
sembra esserci un circolo quello che
chiamano i miei colleghi un loop causale
se non avete se avete paura di questi
circoli allora potete forse tutto
sommato assumere un principio che dice
che il passato è passato e niente
nessuno può cambiarlo nemmeno dio può
far sì che il titanic rossi ha mai
affondato
ma davvero le cose stanno così questa è
una bella foto di un arrivo in volata di
una corsa ciclistica
voi sapete che per un bel po di anni un
po di anni fa un ciclista ha vinto la
più importante delle gare ciclistiche
del mondo il tour de france
però ho passato qualche anno la
federazione ha riconosciuto che alcune
delle sostanze di cui faceva uso questo
ciclista erano dopanti e quindi ha
revocato i titoli che cosa è successo è
successo in qualche modo che un evento
del presente ha modificato qualcosa del
passato e se siete d'accordo con questo
forse potete pensare che alcuni fatti
istituzionali sono in realtà
modificabili dipendono da ciò che
avviene oggi o addirittura che avverrà
domani forse secondo alcuni la realtà
passata non è così granitica è fatta di
fatti molli in un certo senso
modificabili bene che cos'è il tempo
non chiedete ma aveva ragione quel
furgone di agostino aveva proprio
ragione io non lo so so solo che è molto
molto bello cercare di capire che cos'è
il tempo
io sono un'altra cosa che il mio di
tempo è proprio finito